chaos has taken over the streets of
port-au-prince
what started as demonstrations over an
ongoing fuel shortage has grown into a
nationwide protest calling on Haitian
president of nano E's to resign now
diplomat for bilasa market president
promised the Haitian people to lift them
from poverty to pull them out of the
dirt but when he became president he
made everything worse
on Friday thousands took to the streets
authorities in the Haitian capital tried
to control the crowd but with little
effect mobs of angry demonstrators broke
into buildings and looted businesses
[Applause]
several people have died one police
station was vandalized by looters and
nearly set on fire people could be seen
running off with police gear things like
riot shields body armors and anything
else they could carry if the president
really loves Haiti he should resign he
shouldn't wait for there to be more
looting in the streets for him to resign
with nightfall the streets of the
Haitian capital have quieted down and
the city is now under a sort of
self-imposed lockdown Haitian president
Chanel noise continues to call for a
national dialogue but opposition leaders
have instead asked demonstrators to
continue to protest and continue to
pressure the President to resign
meaning the unrest in the country is
likely to continue
Manmadha Paulo al Jazeera port-au-prince